Les vrais marins sont modestes,
ils savent que la mer est la plus forte.
Ici, à Ouessant,
ils sont plus modestes encore
parce qu'ils se méfient et ils ont raison.
Ouessant, l'île du bout de
notre monde, au large de la Bretagne,
l'île sentinelle,
la dernière avant l'infini.
Elle est plus que belle,
les cartes postales ne mentent pas.
Elles nous disent que
les hommes ont jugé bon d'encercler l'île
de balises, de phares, de tourelles,
car pour les marins, Ouessant, c'est ça.
À la croisée des mers où l'océan vient
s'étrangler, les vents sont plus sauvages,
les courants plus furieux,
les brisants plus aigus.
C'est le Cap Horn de l'Europe et ces
cartes postales là ne sont pas en kiosque,
il faut aller les chercher soi-même.
Rares sont les points du globe où
les catastrophes furent aussi meurtrières.
Aujourd'hui, la carte des sauvetages
s'est substituée à celle des naufrages.
J'ai voulu comprendre pourquoi.
Ce fut une sacrée croisière,
une croisière de plein hiver
à bord d'un des plus puissants
remorqueurs du monde, l'Abeille Flandre,
qui garde Ouessant comme on garde
un trésor ou un stock de nitroglycérine.
Cet hiver, les tempêtes ont
été sans égal. Attention, ça va remuer.
Moi, je reste convaincu que pour
faire du sauvetage dans des mers grosses,
comme nous rencontrons en
mer d'Iroise et au large de la Bretagne,
il n'y a qu'un remorqueur pur
comme celui-là pour faire le sauvetage.
Tu es à quai, tu vas
faire ton petit tour en ville.
Tu as ton bip,
il fait beau depuis 15 jours.
Subitement, le bip sonne, il faut
rallier le bord dans les dix minutes.
C'est ça aussi le travail de l'Abeille
Flandre et le travail des sauveteurs.
Est-ce qu'il t'arrive d'avoir peur ?
- Peur en mer ?
Non, si tu as peur en mer, tu ne fais pas
ce métier. Non, je n'ai pas peur en mer.
La météo d'hier était optimiste,
elle n'annonçait qu'une tempête force 11.
En fait, ce dimanche matin, 4 janvier,
sous l'abri des falaises,
au mouillage d'Ouessant,
la force 12 est atteinte
et les rafales dépassent 140 km/h.
Depuis trois jours,
les îliens et les touristes en
quête de réveillon exotique sont bloqués.
Les liaisons maritimes sont interrompues.
L'Ouest de la France est balayé
par une succession de tornades.
Voilà des jours
que nous n'avons revu Brest.
En alerte dès 40 km/h de vent,
l'Abeille quitte son port d'attache.
Ce sont deux heures de gagner
pour atteindre un navire en détresse.
Après le naufrage de l'Amoco Cadiz,
les bateaux abordant la Manche
ou descendant vers l'Atlantique,
sont tenus de respecter
des trajectoires précises.
Comme les voies d'une autoroute,
l'une montante, l'autre descendante.
Cela s'appelle le rail.
Jour et nuit,
les veilleurs d'Ouessant Trafic,
les aiguilleurs de la mer installés
à la pointe de Corsen sur le continent,
contrôlent sur leur radar
la route des mastodontes.
11 h 43, Ouessant Trafic signale
qu'un pétrolier de 180 mètres
a quitté le rail
montant et s'approche de l'île.
Le Capraia n'est pas
perceptible sur les radars du bord,
les guetteurs du sémaphore
de Créac'h, la vigie de l'île,
ont l'impression de revivre
un scénario inoubliable.
L'échouage, voilà 25 ans,
d'un autre pétrolier, l'Olympic Bravery,
juste sous leurs fenêtres.
Sans un mot de trop, comme il convient
aux gens de mer, ils avouent leur crainte.
Il aurait bientôt fallu quitter le port,
la violence du vent est telle
que le remorqueur tire sur son amarre,
au-delà du raisonnable.
Nous sommes à marée
descendante, vent contre courant.
Carlos, le commandant, prévient le
COM, le Centre des Opérations Maritimes,
situé à Brest, qu'il n'y a
pas une seconde à perdre.
Le comportement du
Capraia est incompréhensible,
mais nous sommes dans l'urgence extrême.
Un bateau est un immeuble
de sept étages et trois zones de travail.
La passerelle à 15 mètres
de hauteur, le pont au ras des vagues
et la machine sous la flottaison.
Les mécaniciens ont l'habitude de
dire qu'ils sont les oubliés du sous-sol
et qu'un navire sans propulsion
n'est qu'une ferraille qui flotte.
Sur l'Abeille, ça n'arrive pas.
La maintenance des quatre
moteurs est quotidienne,
on n'a pas le droit à la panne.
Au moment de l'alerte,
trois mots, trois regards suffisent.
Chacun des 12 hommes
d'équipage sait ce qu'il a à faire
et chacun est nécessaire aux autres.
Nous avons appareillé en dix minutes
et débordé la pointe qui nous abritait.
Maintenant, la danse commence.
Nous longeons au plus près
la côte Nord de l'île, la plus rude,
dont Carlos connaît chaque
caillou, à la rencontre du Capraia.
Ça ne va jamais très vite, un bateau.
Même avec 20 000 chevaux lancés au galop,
nous filons un peu plus de 15 nœuds,
un peu plus de 25 km/h.
Le courant nous pousse,
mais nous avons le vent dans le nez.
D'où ces vagues courtes et
hargneuses où nous passons en force.
L'Abeille en a vu d'autres,
il est le seul de tout temps de la zone,
à continuer à faire route
quand les autres s'abritent ou fuient,
quand les hélicos sont cloués au sol.
Nous avons le Capraia au radar
et nous commençons à comprendre.
Son commandant en a
eu assez de rouler terriblement,
encaissant la mer de travers sur le rail.
Il a enfreint les règles,
de modifier son cap
pour prendre les vagues
par l'arrière et fatiguer moins.
Il n'a pas pensé que
le vent le rabattrait vers l'île
et que les hauts fonds
l'aspireraient en direction des brisants.
À la passerelle de l'Abeille,
guettant l'écho du radar,
on est partagé
entre la rage et la crainte,
mais la règle absolue
est de ne pas céder à l'excitation.
On garde son adrénaline pour
soi, c'est obligatoire et nécessaire.
Encore 20 à 30 minutes de route
et ces hommes là-bas, malgré
les mises en garde d'Ouessant Trafic,
savent-ils qu'ils jouent avec la mort ?
Les rochers le long de cette
côte ressemblent à des crocs,
a des dents prêtes à mordre.
Aucun acier n'est assez
dur pour ces mâchoires-là.
Manifestement, le commandant du
Capraia ignore que la petite île de Keller
bien visible par ce temps à grain
et qu'il croit doubler sans problème,
est prolongée par
une chaussée sous-marine,
un semis de roches,
sur lesquelles il va s'éventrer.
Il faut imaginer les dangers du dessous,
les montagnes que la mer cache et
qui déchirent les coques, sournoisement.
Carlos et Guitou,
le chef mécanicien, sont atterrés.
Par cette furie de temps
et si près des cailloux,
il sera difficile, voire impossible,
de crocher une remorque
avant que l'imprudent n'aille à la côte.
Le Capraia, lui, poursuit sa route
comme si de rien n'était. Passera-t-il ?
12 h 22, il est passé à cinq
minutes près, à 2 000 mètres près.
La moindre avarie et ce serait fichu.
Sur l'Abeille, peu à peu,
le soulagement s'installe,
comme on expire violemment
après avoir retenu son souffle.
Carlos n'est pas dupe, le pétrolier
fou lui réserve encore des surprises.
12 h 27, Ouessant est derrière nous.
Les deux navires sont côte à côte,
Carlos prend les choses en main
et il n'est pas au bout de ses peines.
Le Capraia s'apprête à remonter la Manche
et s'obstine à vouloir raser
la côte, celle du continent cette fois.
Il s'en va vers
les roches extrêmes du Finistère.
Pas n'importe
lesquelles, celles de Portsall.
Carlos anticipe, calcule la dérive,
estime l'effet des courants
et avertit Ouessant Trafic.
À ce train-là,
le fantôme d'un pétrolier
transformé en épave
depuis 20 ans, risque de resurgir.
Le plus rageant est que
la manœuvre est simple à ce stade.
S'il le veut, le pétrolier
n'a qu'un coup de barre à donner
pour reprendre 15 degrés
sur la gauche et il serait sauf.
L'aiguilleur d'Ouessant Trafic
s'adresse aux délinquants
avec une courtoisie délibérée.
C'est pour information qu'il lui
signale les dangers qui l'attendent
et il lui demande de regagner
si possible, le tracé du rail.
Cette retenue quand tout le monde
aurait envie d'insulter l'irresponsable,
est le fruit d'un calcul et d'une
expérience. Il est inutile de se défouler.
On prend soin de ne pas provoquer,
chez le commandant du bateau dangereux,
un réflexe de vanité blessé.
La fonction de l'Abeille
n'est pas de faire la police,
elle consiste à
préserver, escorter, sauver.
Carlos attend, pour conseiller
directement son collègue du Capraia,
que ce dernier ait entendu
le message des aiguilleurs de la mer,
mais il a l'oreille dure, le collègue.
Il faut lui répéter
deux fois plutôt qu'une
que sa route est aberrante et fatale.
À la longue, à l'usure, il cède.
Enfin, il écoute, il obéit,
il s'engage à faire de son mieux.
Il prend, un peu tard, la mesure de
sa faute et devine, par la même occasion,
que l'amende, à la première
escale, risque d'être salée.
Alors il file doux et arrondit les angles.
À la passerelle de l'Abeille,
on n'en pense pas moins,
mais le résultat est là,
et c'est le résultat qui compte.
Selon la formule de Carlos,
la bonne manœuvre est celle qui réussit.
15 h 30, fin de partie,
le pétrolier tient son cap,
mais aucun bateau
n'est à l'abri d'un black-out,
d'une panne de générateur
qui le prive d'énergie.
Ce n'est pas plus grave que des
plombs qui sautent dans une maison,
en un quart d'heure,
le courant est revenu.
Le problème, c'est qu'en un quart d'heure,
le pétrolier serait sur les rochers.
Nous l'escortons jusqu'à
ce qu'il ait paré les dangers
et retrouvé la bretelle de son autoroute.
Le but du jeu, au fond,
ce serait qu'il ne se passe rien.
Il a pris une route, a rasé la côte,
mais ce qu'il ne sait toujours pas,
c'est qu'il y a du jusant très fort,
donc il va le ramener vers les cailloux.
En plus, ici on est dans des
fonds de 100 mètres, mais là-bas,
on est dans des fonds de 30 mètres,
donc on aura une mer déferlante.
Il ne pourra plus revenir à ce moment-là.
Je suis rentré en contact avec lui pour
lui expliquer ce qui l'attendait au bout,
et lui faire comprendre que s'il devait
gagner dix degrés de mieux en cap,
c'était maintenant.
Parce qu'après, il n'aurait aucune
échappatoire s'il voulait revenir,
avec la mer de travers.
Pas de remorquage,
rien spectaculaire et pourtant,
l'opération Capraia résume tout
ce qui menace, tout ce qui rôde ici.
En quelques minutes, l'imprudence
et l'ignorance de quelques hommes,
ont failli mettre à mal
le système de prévention
minutieusement construit et
perfectionné après l'Amoco Cadiz.
Tout est fragile en mer.
Quand Carlos a demandé
au commandant du pétrolier maltais
s'il possédait une carte,
ce dernier a répondu par l'affirmative.
Oui, il en possédait une au 200 000ème.
Soit, une carte sur laquelle
on ne distingue ni les chenaux,
ni les courants ni les roches.
À une carte près,
un équipage a failli périr.
La routine reprend le dessus, ni le sang,
ni le pétrole n'ont coulé cette fois-ci.
Dos à la vague, nous roulons moins,
c'est le moment de passer à table.
Le grain monte, le retour sera violent.
Il y a un sauvetage enfin
qui n'était pas un sauvetage,
c'était de la récupération de corps,
qui m'a marqué plus que d'autres.
Charlie, qui est à bord,
était également présent.
C'est quand on a récupéré
les corps du François-Vieljeux,
quand il a coulé au large de la Sardaigne.
Là, je dois dire que
ça a été très pénible,
car c'est la première
fois que ça m'arrivait.
Dans la grande pêche,
j'ai vu des gens disparaître.
Ils disparaissent, c'est un accident
comme le couvreur tombe
de son toit, ça fait partie des risques.
Je crois que ça a marqué
tout le monde pendant longtemps.
Nous avons pris
une plateforme au large de Sartes
pour aller en face.
À la remontée, en face de la Sardaigne,
on est tombé sur ce périlleux naufrage.
Je crois que ça fait partie
des moments les plus pénibles
que j'ai passé à
Abeilles International.
Moi, j'ai mis un an à m'en remettre.
Nous avons la mer du vent.
Même depuis la passerelle,
à 15 mètres de hauteur,
les déferlantes nous surplombent.
Les marins ne sont pas blasés,
on ne perd pas une miette du spectacle.
Le bateau tremble comme une feuille
de tôle, il frémit de la proue à la poupe.
Le gros temps est une danse incessante.
Un art inconscient de rester
d'aplomb, de chercher ses appuis.
C'est une fatigue diffuse,
dont on ne découvre qu'après,
quand ça s'arrête, combien elle
envahit tout le corps et la tête.
Dans les cabines,
on amarre les chaises,
on dépose tout sur le sol
et l'on dort dans sa bannette,
bras et jambes en étoiles,
calé contre les rebords du lit.
Au cours de cette nuit, nous
serons appelés pour une autre escorte.
Je redescends sur terre ou
plutôt sous terre, Confidentielle défense.
Ces couloirs dont l'accès
est interdit, conduisent au COM,
le Centre d'Opérations Maritimes
où sont coordonnées
toutes les actions de l'État en mer.
L'Abeille Flandre est un navire privé
appartenant à la compagnie
des Abeilles International,
mais 365 jours par an, il est
à la disposition de l'État, son affréteur,
et remplit une mission de service public.
Un patron, un seul, gouverne et tranche.
C'est l'amiral Le Dantec, qui
cumule les charges civiles et militaires.
Il faut soumettre à un détecteur,
l'empreinte de son index,
pour le suivre au cœur du système.
Ici, vous êtes dans un endroit secret
qui est le centre de commandement
de la flotte de l'Atlantique,
30 mètres sous
le château de Brest, enterré.
Là, jours et nuits,
des équipes veillent pour commander
la flotte française de l'Atlantique.
L'Amoco Cadiz a été
une prise de conscience générale
de l'urgence de mesures à prendre.
Là, on ne peut pas accuser les pouvoirs
publics d'être restés les bras ballants.
On a donné aux préfets
maritimes des pouvoirs considérables,
notamment, celui de
mise en demeure d'un bateau
constituant un danger
pour le littoral français.
Dans ce cas, on demande
à l'armateur et au capitaine du navire
de faire cesser
le danger qu'il représente.
Faute de quoi, à ses frais et à ses
risques, nous prendrons toutes les mesures
pour empêcher que le
bateau provoque une catastrophe.
Je reviens sur la mise en demeure,
il y a toute une culture de la négociation
entre le remorqueur
et le bateau qu'il va assister.
Tout ça,
c'est fini ce temps-là.
Vous avez raison, c'est fini,
car l'accident de l'Amoco
Cadiz, c'est ça qui s'est produit.
Les négociations interminables
entre le commandant du bateau, son
armateur et les compagnies de remorquage.
Aujourd'hui, la mise en demeure
me permet d'obliger
un bateau à prendre la remorque.
La loi française m'autorise à le faire
et nous avons l'Abeille Flandre
qui est capable, elle l'a prouvé,
de tenir, même par très mauvais
temps, un gros pétrolier en difficulté.
Pour toi, l'amiral Le Dantec est d'abord
un supérieur hiérarchique et un affréteur
ou c'est d'abord un marin ?
- C'est d'abord un marin.
Quand vous avez des liaisons
radios avec le commandant Claden,
à la passerelle de l'Abeille Flandre.
Vos rapports sont d'abord des rapports
hiérarchiques ou de marin à marin ?
Des rapports de marin à marin
faits d'estime mutuelle et de confiance.
Quand le commandant
Claden nous propose une solution
face à une situation
de danger ou d'urgence,
nous tenons le plus
grand compte de ses avis.
Militaires ou civils,
fonctionnaires ou non,
les gardiens du rail
partagent la même mission
et sont d'abord des gens
de mer, amoureux de leurs côtes.
Quel est votre oiseau préféré ?
- Le fou de Bassan,
car c'est un oiseau
qu'on ne voit qu'au large.
Qui a un superbe voilier
qui fait jusqu'à 1m80 d'envergure,
blanc avec le bout des ailes noires
et le bec jaune.
Si je croyais à la métempsychose,
dans une vie future,
j'aimerais bien être un fou de Bassan.
Mardi 13 janvier, nous
voilà repartis en alerte météo.
La mer est dure, mais le pire est à venir.
Une violente tempête,
de force dix à 11, est imminente.
Carlos a la fièvre et reste
couché, pas pour longtemps.
À 14 h 01, le Nautila, un porte-conteneurs
de 85 mètres appelle au secours.
Il est en avarie totale de machines
à 4 miles dans l'Ouest de l'île de Sein.
Pour l'instant, le vent et
le courant lui permettent de tenir,
mais l'un et l'autre vont basculer
et le naufrage inévitable.
Il faut faire vite, à deux heures
près, la manœuvre sera compromise
et le vent commence à tourner.
Conseil de guerre
à l'approche du navire en détresse.
On fait le point,
on arrête une tactique
avant de passer à l'action.
Lionel, le bosco, règne sur le pont,
le territoire de tous les dangers,
où chacun doit
immédiatement trouver ses marques.
Dominique, le lieutenant, est chargé
de la coordination avec la passerelle.
Il expédiera aussi,
grâce au fusil lance-amarres,
un fin cordage aux
matelots du navire assisté.
Un cordage au bout duquel
sera préparé la remorque.
Sur la plage arrière,
contre le vent qui atteint force dix
et contre les paquets
de mer imprévisibles,
on n'a qu'une défense, qu'une
armure, la combinaison tous temps.
Le reste est affaire
de vigilance et de réflexe.
La porte va s'ouvrir, comme se
lève un rideau, dehors, ça piaule.
Jean-Marc, le second
maître, est né et vit à Camaret.
Sa maison surplombe
les vagues devenues son lieu de travail.
Lionel et lui forment un duo
assez rodé pour se passer de répétitions.
Pour préparer la remorque,
le câble qui va relier les deux navires,
chacun connaît par cœur
l'enchaînement des opérations
et chacun garde un œil
sur une éventuelle déferlante.
Il pleut à seaux, l'eau
douce et salée se confondent.
Les marins appellent ça,
le grain de la manœuvre.
Les bateaux à la dérive,
en feu, désemparés, inondés,
Lionel et Jean-Marc
en ont vu de toutes sortes.
Le geste du sauveteur est le même,
mais chaque sauvetage est différent.
Ils sont avec leurs matelots,
les voltigeurs du bord.
Quand ça se complique, il n'est pas rare
que Jean-Paul le
cuisinier, vienne les aider.
Les hommes de la machine,
abrités dans la réserve,
attendent leurs tours
quand la remorque sera tournée.
Ce sont des clients sérieux,
le commandant du Nautila,
dès qu'il a compris
que la panne était grave,
a pris toutes les dispositions
auprès de son armateur.
La mise en demeure du préfet maritime,
signifiée à 15 h, n'a posé aucun problème.
Maintenant, c'est à Dominique
le lieutenant, de jouer, de viser juste.
On n'est pas à la fête
foraine, la partie peut tourner mal.
Les deux coques
sont dangereusement proches.
Carlos et l'autre capitaine
ont parfaitement réglé le ballet.
L'équipage du Nautila est à
son poste sur le gaillard d'avant.
Ce sont des pros, des
vrais, acrobates et coordonnés.
Ils ne laissent pas filer l'occasion,
la première tentative sera la bonne.
Pourtant, le vent est si fou
que les mouettes volent à reculons.
Carlos, là-haut, à l'abri des
vitres, ne quitte pas son porte-voix.
Quand il était lieutenant,
lui aussi travaillait sur le pont
avec les hommes d'équipage.
Il en connaît les périls et
une obsession lui reste présente.
De perdre un homme !
Je crois que c'est la plus
grosse peur, c'est ça, avant tout.
Ça peut arriver à n'importe
quel moment, même par beau temps
et ça, c'est vraiment ma grosse frayeur.
D'autant plus qu'auparavant,
j'étais avec eux sur le pont.
Je sais comment
on travaillait sur le pont
car on avait confiance
au gars qui était en haut.
Il ne faut pas qu'ils
perdent cette confiance.
Les câbles souffrent et fouettent.
C'est peu de chose, une remorque.
Un cassant de polypropylène
puis des torrents d'acier.
Quelques centimètres
de diamètre seulement,
mais cela requiert des treuils géants
et cela déplace des montagnes de métal.
Quand ça cède,
ça peut tuer en balayant le pont.
Reste à apprivoiser le monstre,
à le dompter peu à peu.
Savoir lâcher, savoir reprendre.
Ne pas être emporté par le navire qu'on
assiste, c'est l'art du fin manœuvrier.
Carlos et Guitou jouent
des manettes avec dextérité.
Vincent, le second mécanicien, surveille
le bon défilement de la remorque.
Un équipage, c'est une symphonie.
Lionel se sèche, l'essentiel de la partie
est gagné, d'un coup l'ambiance se détend.
On s'aventure même à prononcer
le mot qui fait trembler tous les marins.
Mardi 13, 13 à bord
et on n'a pas arrêté de parler de lapin.
Le Nautila suit docilement
l'Abeille à rythme soutenu, six nœuds,
le commandant est pressé
de mener le bateau à bon port
avant que la mer ne soit plus hargneuse.
La remorque est immergée
et sert d'amortisseur.
Les pannes, c'est normal, tous
les navires ou presque en connaissent.
On stoppe, on répare durant quatre ou
cinq heures, et tout rentre dans l'ordre.
Autour d'Ouessant,
on n'a pas le temps de réparer.
La houle est trop forte,
la dérive trop rapide.
Le rail sert précisément à repousser
les cargos assez loin, jusqu'à 27 miles,
pour qu'un remorqueur ait
le temps de se porter à leur secours
et de recommencer
la manœuvre si nécessaire.
Après 20 ans de station
à Brest, l'Abeille Flandre a sauvé,
comme aujourd'hui, 176 navires,
notamment 11 pétroliers,
sept transporteurs chimiques,
deux ferries et 37 chalutiers.
Son homologue, l'Abeille
Languedoc, basé à Cherbourg,
aligne un palmarès comparable.
Le coût d'une seule
catastrophe, celle de l'Amoco Cadiz,
représente 120 années
d'affrètement du remorqueur.
À 18 h 35, le pilote du port
de Brest monte à bord du Nautila,
qui sera mené à quai
par le remorqueur portuaire.
L'Abeille repart vers le large pour la
nuit, le temps que le coup de vent passe.
Les bateaux que vous
allez assister, ils sont anciens ?
Des fortunes de mer,
il y en a, mais autrement...
Non, tu peux avoir des bateaux
neufs qui tombent en panne aussi.
C'est le poids ?
Oui. Déjà, ils ont remonté
tout le golfe de Gascogne.
Ce n'est pas le coin
le mieux au niveau du temps.
Il y en a beaucoup qui remontent d'Afrique
ou de plus loin, du golfe persique.
Une fois que tu as pris
une branlée dans le golfe de Gascogne,
les bateaux sont fatigués, c'est le coin.
J'ai plus d'amour pour
l'équipage que pour le bateau.
Parce que dans ce type de métier,
le bateau est important, c'est vrai.
On a l'amour du bateau,
mais pas l'amour du bel objet,
mais de quelque chose qui
doit fonctionner, qui est un outil.
Autant que cet outil
soit bien huilé et soit parfait.
On les aime ces bateaux-là.
Tous les marins aiment leurs bateaux.
Regarde ça, ça va blanchir après.
C'est la Rolls, ici, c'est la Rolls.
Tout le reste est fait.
C'est vrai que
la particularité du remorquage,
c'est que le bateau
est englobé dans l'équipage.
C'est l'équipage qui l'entretient,
ce sont eux qui vont se battre.
Ils vont faire les choses pour
que, justement, il soit bien entretenu,
mais c'est eux,
derrière, qui vont souffrir.
Si toutes ces opérations sont réussies,
c'est 98 pourcent grâce aux
hommes qui sont en bas à la machine
et à ceux qui sont sur le pont.
Vous ne vous attachez pas avec des harnais
quand vous travaillez sur le pont ?
Ce n'est pas pratique.
Si tu vois le paquet
de mer arriver par l'arrière,
on va se cacher derrière le treuil.
Si je suis amarré là,
je ne peux pas aller derrière.
C'est pour ça qu'on ne veut
pas avoir de harnais ni s'amarrer.
Alors, comment fais-tu avec tes gars ?
- Déjà, je les place.
Depuis le temps, chacun sait à peu près
son poste à part quand il y a de nouveaux.
Sinon, il y a toujours
un qui regarde derrière.
Dès qu'il voit le paquet de mer
arriver, on se met derrière le treuil
ou on s'accroche aux mains courantes
et on fait drapeau.
Vous partez à l'horizontal ?
- Oui et après, tu y retournes.
Depuis le temps, on a l'habitude.
Des fois, on part quand même avec.
Alors t'embrasses le rouleau,
t'embrasses la lice, n'importe quoi.
Pas les meilleurs souvenirs ?
Non, mais ça va,
tu as des bleus, c'est tout.
Quand tu lis dans le journal que
vous êtes des héros, tu réagis comment ?
Je pense que les gars
le méritent, ils n'osent pas en parler.
C'est vrai, quand je suis
là-haut, je vois ce qu'ils font.
Ce sont de toutes petites
personnes au milieu de l'eau.
À des moments, quand
on a un gros paquet de mer,
je ne vois plus personne, j'ai
l'impression que je les ai tous perdus,
ils sont toujours là et ils retournent
derrière. Je crois qu'ils le méritent.
Non, on n'est pas des héros.
Je vais te dire une chose,
le doute m'habite, le doute m'habite.
Ça me fait sourire.
Ça me fait sourire, je pense que
les héros, il y en a plein partout alors.
Ça fait un peu sourire parce que
des hommes exceptionnels, il y en a plein.
Il y a les chirurgiens, les pompiers, ...
- Les héros de la mer.
Il n'y a pas à se sentir
de gloriole plus qu'ailleurs.
Non, alors ce n'est pas du tout mon genre.
On n'est pas des héros,
il n'y a rien, on fait notre travail.
Ça fait sourire, ma foi, si on considère
que nous sommes des héros, soit.
Oh, c'est la pudeur, ça !
C'est la pudeur du marin,
c'est un peu le problème général.
Tous les marins sont comme ça.
Que ce soit le pêcheur
ou le gars de la SNSM.
Je pense que leur
travail à eux, sur l'Abeille,
pour eux, c'est encore plus
dangereux que ce qu'on fait.
Parce qu'ils ont du
matériel quand ils travaillent.
Ils ont des câbles derrière,
c'est sur un remorquage et tout,
c'est extrêmement dangereux.
Alors qu'ici, il suffit d'être
bien accroché dans le bateau.
C'est beaucoup plus facile.
Vous avez un point commun,
vous sortez quand les autres rentrent.
Oui, on est là pour ça, pour sortir.
Celui qui a peur, il ne faut
pas qu'il fasse partie de la SNSM.
Le monde d'Ouessant est
un club qui ne dit pas son nom,
celui des frères de la côte.
Personne ne l'avoue,
mais une admiration
mutuelle unit ces compagnons.
C'est intéressant parce qu'on
rencontre des gens des autres milieux.
On s'aperçoit qu'on est pas différent,
quelle que soit
la carrière qu'on ait faite.
Entre un patron pêcheur,
un patron de remorqueur, etc.
Il n'y a finalement
pas de grosses différences.
Quels sont les
grands principes de la SNSM ?
Les règles d'or de la SNSM
sont particulières au sens qu'ici,
c'est du bénévolat.
Les règles d'or, ce sont
les marins qui vont sauver les marins
et dans les coins qu'ils connaissent.
Derrière les cailloux, répète
souvent Carlos, il y a des hommes.
Des hommes qui ont en
commun une culture, un savoir.
Les bénévoles qui
interviennent près des roches,
ont les mêmes réflexes et langages
que les sauveteurs de l'Abeille,
la même patience
et la même disponibilité.
Être à quai, à Brest,
c'est aussi une grosse partie du travail.
C'est toute la phase d'attente, stand-by.
Pour deux minutes d'action passionnante,
on passe pas mal de
temps en stand-by, en attente.
Passer des semaines et
des semaines, en bonne saison,
ça amène un maximum
de temps passé à quai.
C'est vrai que c'est dur, c'est dur.
Dur d'agir, dur de ne pas agir.
Le métier de sauveteur
est un métier sérieux,
minutieux, trop minutieux
qui exige sa contrepartie.
Revenir à quai entre
deux alertes, deux opérations,
c'est bizarre,
ce n'est pas vraiment revenir.
On est rivé au bateau
45 jours de rang jusqu'à la relève.
On a envie de souffler, mais en
même temps, on a horreur d'attendre.
On continue d'écouter
les radios 24 h sur 24,
et l'on s'autorise à
décompresser si la météo s'améliore.
Les amis, les femmes,
les enfants, passent à bord
quand il a été possible
de les prévenir d'une escale.
L'autre vie, par bouffées, vous entoure
et vous effleure comme un parfum.
Vagabonds sans rivage,
dont certains tatouages
évoquent l'anarchie et la révolution,
mais lui, le Malabar,
lui qui n'a peur de rien.
L'homme dit, je vous préviens
je suis le maître à bord,
moi seul, je suis le maître.
Parmi les proches frères de la côte,
les capitaines des bateaux
de la Penn Ar Bed,
la compagnie qui
assure la desserte d'Ouessant.
Au plus fort de la tempête de janvier,
600 personnes attendent
quatre jours durant, bloqués sur l'île.
Le cinquième jour,
les responsables de la Penn
Ar Bed envoyent à Ouessant
leurs deux navires les plus
robustes pour délivrer les prisonniers.
L'Abeille est là, montant la garde.
Carlos et son équipage
ont confiance dans leurs collègues,
dont plusieurs ont
navigué sur le remorqueur,
mais par ce temps,
notre présence est rassurante.
Jamais peut-être le petit port
du Stiff n'a connu pareille cohue.
Heureusement, les candidats au
voyage ne discernent pas, comme nous,
dans quel chaudron du diable
se débattent les deux traversiers
qui arrivent l'un après l'autre, à vide.
Il faut être sur l'Abeille pour voir ça.
L'embarquement est planifié
soigneusement par groupe de dix
et les bateaux repartent,
chacun chargé de 300 passagers
tassés comme
des sardines au ras des brisants.
La manœuvre est impeccable.
À la passerelle de l'Abeille,
nous observons sur le qui-vive,
l'incroyable conjugaison
du courant et du vent,
dans le chenal qui sépare
Ouessant de Molène, sa voisine,
et qui s'appelle le Fromveur.
En breton, cela
signifie le grand courant.